[Musique]
jetez un coup d'oeil à ta chambre
tiens et souhaite y un droit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gc
[Musique]
mais on
tiens bien
alors on le met où celui là près de la
fenêtre ici ou d'accords tiens moi ça on
va le monter ensemble on va y arriver
mais papa tu le monde à l'envers
si dans l'autre sens tu sais quoi
et si tu allais jouer en bas un papa va
finir tout seul ça va aller questionné
sur sûr
[Musique]
en fait
salut
[Musique]
je l'avais la couleur salut salut salut
à l'italie je m'appelle meyrals et jade
est là là oui c'est pas facile de se
faire des copains par ici comment tu
sais pas je le sais c'est tout ça veut
dire que tu as pas d'amis est ce que tu
veux être mon ami tu voudrais bien
vraiment mais il faudrait que tu suives
le règlement d'accord règle 1 pour être
copains pour être amis peut-être mon
avis ok règles de copains à deux je veux
savoir tout savoir oui savoir tout de
toi
vraiment tout oui je veux savoir tout
est secret règle 3 de notre loi pour
être copains tout doit se faire dans la
main on doit se tenir la main nord
écoute règles codes du contrat ne t'en
va pas dit wang pas à plus de 5 mètres
de moi 5 m un deux trois quatre cinq
règles simples pour être copains
antic a cette fois pour voir en toile et
on va faire comment attend on fait ça
deux fois
non non non là je tourne shake shack et
puis on fait encore deux fois sa
ânonnant attend s'ils trouvaient non non
non elle laisse tomber on fera ce
tchèque si jamais on dépasse les 5
mètres du contrat c'est bon pour toi réd
le cse du contrat pour être un ami tu
dois garder le contrat sur toi bon je
vais quand même réfléchir un peu
d'accord ça lui a t-on je croyais que tu
étais mon ami et ben tu fais pas de doux
j'arrive pas à dormir et sept ans dormir
d'accord tu dois être en forme pour
demain des copains de classe seront
super
et t'es qui toi c'est toi qui as mangé
mon chewing gum
[Musique]
n'aie pas peur de moi je ne meurs pas
tissé et lipides
tu peux garder mon chewing gums tu veux
samedi j'aurai mon argent de poche
alors je pourrais m'en racheter un
meeting
bon appétit tu peux manger le fromage
avec la croûte
je reviens tout à l'heure tu écris tu
gardes et il a bien dormi
oui amuse-toi bien et travaille bien oui
et toi repose toi bien merci pas
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
tu dois être meyrals c'est ça oui je
suis ta maîtresse nos jours les
bienvenus tu peux accrocher son manteau
d'accord je suis la maman de meyrals
alors tu viens dans ma classe oui sur ce
j'ai l'impression d'accord il fait super
bon travail bien un bistrot bien oui
bisous salut salut salut salut d'haïti
les enfants
je vous présente meyrals elle vient
d'emménager dans le quartier est détenu
et bonjour bonjour va t'asseoir à côté
de vito di zot va commencer sa
présentation d'accord d'accord tu es
prêt way or pardon je vais vous parler
des eaux
parce qu'en fait je fais collection dos
j'en ai plein celui là ouais très bien
tiens ceci par exemple est un os de
boeuf mais la plus belle pièce de ma
collection c'est un crainte de moutons
je les trouvais au bord d'une route au
portugal il y avait encore de la viande
dessus oui mais j'ai bien tout nettoyer
c'est dégoûtant bon à votre avis qu'est
ce que c'est regardez bien
vous en avez tous déjà eu dans votre
assiette
bah
[Musique]
un poulet ouais hier j'ai mangé des
cuisses de poulet avec de la purée
maintenant il est dans ma collection
mais il manque une chose importante et
c'est quoi ça une côte ou quoi non c'est
une pelote une pelote de réjection de
hibou le hibou avale sa proie en entier
et ensuite il a dit géré dans son
estomac et après il recrache une espèce
de boulettes dos et de poils qu'on
appelle une pelote de réjection alors si
vous en trouvez une en classe de
découverte vous me prévenez c'est sûr si
je trouve un truc dégoûtant je te donne
comptions ouais c'est la fin de ma
présentation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
laisse tomber
swisscom sa passion
[Musique]
on va au nisa
est ce que c'est vrai le truc duigou
pauvres petites bêtes
voilà
pourquoi te fais ça ça fait des jours
que j'attends que ça arrive
désolé je tends trouverait une autre non
je l'attrapé et je la remettrai dans la
torah du chiqué je vais me débrouiller
[Musique]
j'avais dit que c'était pas facile de se
faire des amis d'anne moi ton contrat je
vais le signer pour de vrai oui bonne
d'un stylo bille non attends bouge pas
je vais en chercher
alors c'est bon t'as relu le contrat en
entier ça va mais si tu attends à tiens
voilà merci maintenant on est des vrais
amis oui tiens je te le rend non règle 6
tu dois garder le contrat sur toi oui
attend quoi
règle 2 4 ah oui et on fait le tchèque
la carte est ok docteur ndoye et gilet
de rechange tchèque paire de chaussettes
tchèque sous vêtements chics et une
paire de bottes
tiens tu perds tu as tout ce qu'il te
faut on ferme
il manque juste une lampe de poche ok
vas te coucher je vais chercher ça
d'accord
est ce qu'il peut bien être
c'est pas possible tu à vérifier les
étiquettes sur les cartes au ct kg est
typique sécurité et veux-tu retourner au
lit et voilà ouais arrête
non je vais avoir peur au travail je la
met dans la poche de devant
allez bonne nuit ça aussi au tien sacs
de couchage tchèque cech
bonne nuit au travail ferme bien la
porte
[Musique]
alors c'était bon je tenais à apporter
encore debout petit poussin ou est ce
que tu vas aujourd'hui en place débit
couverte de boue et zou
[Musique]
non c'est dégoûtant assises et achètent
de la mort-aux-rats s'il te plaît oui ou
une [ __ ] ya plein de crottes de
souris dans la chambre de meyrannes ben
willacy d'accord pip pip sort de la vie
dépêche toi
[Musique]
speed des pipes n'ai pas peur de moi ma
maman veut tuer hip hip meira tu es
encore les deux bouts on va être en
retard je veux pas y aller si tu y vas
en a promis à ta maîtresse et que les
arrête ton cinéma élèves soit on y va
maman quoi j'ai de la fièvre
des boutons partout sur le bras regarde
je me sens complètement fly and am
s'il te plaît ma
c'est moi chocolat laisse-moi voix
est-ce que ça me tue en cous des
critiques de moustiques
[Musique]
j'ai mal à l'aise
elle épousera gars je tiens même plus de
vous comment
mon petit poussin inquiète
ça va être super la classe découverte
tu ne me crois pas maman
mais c'est pas des blagues d'azur
ah ah
je suis vraiment malade
c'est super chaud et puis très froid en
maman
dirait qu'ils sont encore d'accord
d'accord tu sais quoi on va prendre la
température
ok retourne me coucher lipides epide
voilà je vais prendre la température
non en fait ça va mieux j'avais juste un
petit peu peur d'y aller
quoi tu viens mais ça va bien on y va
via maman je veux pas être en retard
vous êtes là je vais rentrer à temps je
peux te dire envoie thierry j'ai pris de
la mort aux rats et des [ __ ] à
souris
oh là là tu vas nous manquer quoi mais
je suis plus un bébé
quoi qu'est ce qui t'arrive
je suis un peu nerveux si tous
[Musique]
bonjour mes rêves bonjour bonjour je
suis la maîtresse de meyrannes bling
allez viens faire un gros qu'elle
s'allie au revoir
c'est à quoi alors rien c'est un hamster
je peux le voir ou ici viens t'asseoir
avec moi je peux t'asseoir ici non
désolé vie thomas garder une place je
sais que les animaux sont interdits en
classe verte
[Musique]
règle numéro 4 pouces toi pitot tu veux
la plus passage on avance avance et ne
restez pas dans le couloir allez vous
asseoir trouver vite une place
allez allez une vraie souris elle a
apprivoisé presque tout va bien par ici
oui oui mais super ok vous pouvez me
passer le micro
merci tout le monde est content de
partir super pour moi aussi on va y
aller on vous pouvez démarrer
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez
[Musique]
les
vous
c'est un bonhomme allez vous demander
sans moi mon contrat mais je veux le
garder il me rend le tout de suite
ne restez pas planter là pour vous aider
les autres allez zou
cette valise
qu'est ce que tu cherches vous avez vu
ma valise qui arrive en écriture sac
rouge
j'ai fait mes gars des minutes
on est encore à me oui mais tu dois
respecter les règles ok vous écoutez moi
les enfants
alors voilà en fait j'ai fait une petite
erreur je croyais qu'on avait des
chambres de 6 mais ce sont des chambres
de 4 finalement donc on va devoir
réorganiser la répartition dans les
chambres les enfants du calme ne vous en
faites pas on va faire de nouveaux
groupes et non mais mal c'est pas juste
ok calmez vous les affronts à l'aider le
graal du cam
merci voilà ce que quelqu'un va choisir
un camarade de chambre et celui là on
choisira un autre et ainsi de suite
comme ça on aura rempli les chambres et
tout est là bien au jason bien la
laisser le passé ne tient que tu va
choisir au premier vas-y meira du feu
super à toi murale choisi quelqu'un
vitaux vite au hockey à toi
c'est une choisi on ira faire du
shopping ensemble d'après désisté si tu
seras dans leur chemin non il ne m'a
même pas choisi en plus moi j'étais
chemin je ne suis pas d'accord
dc et nul n'y a pas deux mais vous êtes
dans la chambre 15 à les faire voler
allez ensuite ayew qui veut tu choisiras
tyrone à toi allez alexander à toi
ouf
c'est par là
bien
prolonge prudence prenant faudrait pas
croire qu on est copains maintenant il
faut casser bourdis les jambes et les
stresser c'est quoi
rien en rire toute façon ça m'intéresse
pas et puis c'est interdit les animaux
ici même les hamsters c'est pas un
hamster c'est une souris ma mère voulait
la tuer alors je devais amener ici c'est
interdit de parler avec elle elle doit
d'abord signer le contrat d'amitié c'est
obligé on comptera d'amitié c'est quoi
sérieux personne va signer ce truc
numéral la signer et ses vraies règles
qu'être oui 5 m tu me le pass vous êtes
tous tard et fouette début pour signer
ce machin t'as pas le droit de lui
parler mais j'ai pas envie de lui parler
ce serait bien de la laisser gambader
non quand c'est pas ça elle va s'enfuir
mais tu peux pas la tenir tout le temps
à temps
mais ya là dedans
elle pourra dormir et courir équipe
pas question inspection des sceaux vite
faut tout ranger oui allez vous laver
les mains maintenant ensuite descendu au
réfectoire
wendy elle variera doré la souris la
maîtresse alors d ibra vos tu peux
descendre au réfectoire et je vois que
vous avez encore un peu de rangement à
faire un
alors papa pas l'action on met le paquet
tiens je t'en prie la vidéo montre moi
tes mains d'abord tient et vous aussi au
passage
alors voyons voir si ses propres tout ça
dessus dessous dessus dessous de nickel
allez vous asseoir
attention c'est quoi ça venez ans mais
là un vase y passe
je dois d obéir à la règle 4 c'est une
urgence
[Musique]
c'est délicieux
ou est ce que tu vas comme ça allez tu
vas à l'état soir maintenant comme tout
le monde d'accord et madame il lui fait
mal
non c'est bon désolé ça va chez nous les
colts pas là je comprends mais gardez
votre cas
[Musique]
maîtriser gardez votre sang froid avec
les enfants de m je comprends je sais
bien que vous devez faire respecter les
règles mais soyez plus de vitteaux elle
bat à ça ça se reproduira plus fine et
moment
[Musique]
passe moi ça te plait tient au travail
la vie boulot il faut y aller c'est
ballot
avec six abandons sur un petit pont et
tout sera pas ni quels types tape comme
yann moix géminées ya du boulot ont
balayé tout plateau
ni de papier aucune de miettes blier ya
du boulot
[Musique]
des marques une patty [ __ ] y est
ya du boulot c'est en chantant on s'est
bien vite aux pratiquants
tu m'as savoir plus vit vraiment fait ce
mois-ci mais y'a du boulot océan chaud
[Musique]
ça va me dit t'as pas pris de bottes ci
mais elles sont dans ma valise
tu ferais mieux de les mettre regarde
moi j'ai des supers semelle et un autre
truc important
ces nombres d'épaisseur un pull à notre
pull et puis un t-shirt et une veste par
dessus il vaut toujours mieux être prêt
en cas de vent de pluie d'orage de
foudre ou de froid mais j'ai pas pois du
tour c'est moi arrêtez de me suis tout
le temps - tirez vous j'en peux plus tu
es pas gentille ça allait venir
je peux rester avec vous tu peux la
mettre dedans c'est vrai tu peux pas lui
parler parce qu'on a un contrat
tiens vas-y
aux données signé mois plâtre
[Musique]
va plus loin que 5 m nous on suit les
règles c'est quoi le plancher j'aime pas
oui tu aimes souvenant oui oui oui oui
donc quoi le plein
[Musique]
on va commencer ici on a tout un
ensemble de feuilles de gland de noir et
de graines
c'est ce qu'on veut trouver pour notre
jeu des correspondances et vous allez
former des équipes avec vos camarades
des chambres et chaque équipe devra
chercher dans la forêt les arbres ou les
arbustes qui correspondent à ses
feuilles ou et ses fruits étaient
compris oui très bien alors la première
équipe sera l'équipe orange dont jason
vitaux mais khaled et si tu arrêtes mois
est-ce qu'on peut les prendre
oui équipe bleu nao mitico mylan et
kyowa au riz son coup
en ligne
waouh vous avez vu ue
regardez là bas c'est bon arbre non
waouh génial de voir quoi
c'est une pelote non mais c'est super
c'est un pinson c'était un pinson c'est
dégoûtant pauvre piot c'est juste la
nature qui fonctionne comme ça tu te
souviens tu avais eu de la peine pour la
coccinelle la coccinelle qui a l'air si
gentille est en réalité super agressive
elle massacre les pucerons à part à
faire tous les jours à festin c'est pas
méchant c'est la nature les pucerons
c'est ça aurait peur en tant qu'allemand
jeu tranquillement à pucerons bref elle
est gonflée à son tour par un pinson et
d'un coup c'est fini le prédateur
devient la croatie
avis c'est pas méchant c'est la nature
les coccinelles si ça n'aurait que et le
pain sont bien cachés dans les airs ne
voit pas que de moi l'homme sert mais
l'armé blanche elle a repéré sur nyon
certes on goûte et c'est pas méchant
c'est la nature les pinceaux c'est sa
nourriture
[Musique]
les fermiers ne paie qu'une bouchée du
poinçon mélo renault arrive soudain à
l'horizon attend patiemment
pour neelie kroes un quota c'est pas
méchant c'est la nature
les experts si sa nourriture
c'est la nature
vous fait la loi un jour le chasseur à
jour
[Musique]
il a plu
il ya tous les deux
on est venu ici comme ça j'ai pas envie
qu'elle habille ma boîte de maquillage
d'accord typique
tu devrais la laisser courir un peu ça
lui ferait du bien de profiter de la
nature
oui je crois qu'elle s'embête un peu là
dedans mais j'ai pas envie qu'elle se
perd dans la forêt malta qu'elle a
promené en laisse comme un chien tu
rigoles
elle tiendra encore moins longtemps
commence à moins longtemps les souris
une maison sa vie pas longtemps en
captivité
tu ferais mieux de la laisser partir
ok
c'est bien ici comment droite oui
parfait l'esma s'amuser
[Musique]
regardez on tirait une bille
regarde
oui
petit chien bouge pas
les vous ça mange pas les souris
[Musique]
mirada temps c'est une engeance pip pip
by philippe je crois qu'on l'a perdu
ah ouais oui on doit rentrer ta question
je rentre pas sans pipe
il faut qu'on rentre t'as pas d'ordre à
me donner quoi on s'amusait bien dans la
nature oui c'est vrai mais râle il vient
par là tu dois rentrer quand je
t'appelle tu veux dîner nous attend
voilà des fripes froide
bon appétit après vous irait directement
au lit est ce que ces comprimés canada
meyrannes meyrals oui la banane
je déteste cible tenez vous dirai rien
votre maîtresse merci je n'ai pas la
faute de luis bout il devait avoir faim
toi aussi tu aimes bien la viande
[Musique]
tu le savais depuis le début que le
hibou mangerait pip pip
si sa faute t'es pas d'accord
quoi que c'est de sa faute non pas
vraiment
[Musique]
non tu peux pas faire ça
vous le savez ils le seraient ils
savaient ce qui était plus tim moss
avait il le savait il me semble il le
savait depuis début le savez maintenant
je suis tout seul il faut laisser
bêtement boxun criminelle
ils ont laissé mourir baby j'aurais dû
rester chez moi faire croire que le
savait mais il le savait depuis
ça va
[Musique]
je savais ce joli bébé tousse
et même la nature se seraient rencontrés
même
j'ai pensé
[Musique]
pis
j'vois puis les voit plus jamais les
voix soit simple ici quelle bande de
crétins
tu me manques l'ifip ma souris qui
étaient tellement mignonne qu'est ce que
j'aimerais rentrer à la maison le savez
qu ils le savaient et ils le savaient
depuis début kg savez le savaient ils le
savaient ils le savaient
[Musique]
et
que savait
nous
mairal tu ne vas pas jouer dehors
non pourquoi je me sens pas bien
qu'est ce que tu as c'est la nature je
peux faire autre chose oui bien sûr tu
peux aider à la cuisine facile bon
courage tout va bien oui
et tu peux le relâcher dans la nature
non je veux pas or va quand même pas le
mettre dans les toilettes
qu'est-ce que si j'ai trouvé un escargot
dans la salle
[Musique]
puig
merci monsieur oui je cherche à ibou oui
s'il y en a il ya même un hibou grand
duc dans ce bois un magnifique spécimen
savais où je peux le trouver
oui il habite dans un grand être pas
très loin d'ici par là où exactement
monsieur ben en fait à temps je crois
que le plus simple c'est que je te
montre ça fait quand même une petite
trotte tu sers alors nous sommes ici
d'accord et si tu prends le sentier qui
est là tu passeras devant un étang oui
j'étais emprunter votre fait
oui bien sûr tiens à c'est une bonne
idée
donc tu dois suivre cet aller et ensuite
tu va emprunter un chemin assez sinueux
et là tu tomberas sur le être tu vois tu
peux pas le rater il est énorme
c'est bon j'ai voir à temps c'est
l'envers mais oui c'est ben oui bravo la
maîtresse si tu te promènes tout seul
dans la forêt le hibou a pris pip pip ma
petite souris aux bas mon avis il ya des
chances pour qu'elle soit morte depuis
longtemps les grands ducs mange toutes
sortes de proies tu sais c'est normal
ils ont faim et oui il faut bien vivre
il mange des mulots des oiseaux j'en ai
même vu manger un lièvre en entier il
n'y a pas longtemps au regard de la
hausse ce qu un pivert aux eaux
il est magnifique non oui bon nathan
fais pas trop il faut accepter les
règles de la vie c'est la nature un
d'accord
c'est un pou yo à grand jour s'il ça
alors oui c'est bien ça oh
tu ne pourras pas à la sauver
[Musique]
mon
tiens
[Musique]
vas-y recommencé voilà papa papa pas là
là il faut qu'on réfléchisse à ce qu'on
fait pour la veillée
on pourrait faire une danse je sais pas
bien danser et puis jason non plus un du
zen il peut à meyrals tu voudrais faire
quoi je sais pas encore je peux danser
dans mon fauteuil roulant si tu veux
mais râle je m'en fiche
[Musique]
les râles oui ce que tu vas en dortoir à
temps je viens avec toi
[Musique]
dizy vitaux réveillez-vous quillard
meira les parties je crois qu'elle va
chercher peep-toe
[Musique]
enfin
bon
[Musique]
on va t'aider
et s'ils espèrent dans la forêt coucou
je suis la mayral ça va je sais que
piper morte
on pense et était parti la chercher bah
oui c'est ça je veux trouver la pelote
du hibou ah ouais pourquoi pour avoir un
souvenir d'elle regardez le hibou habite
là à d'accord pour larissa c'est le
sentier qui passe devant les cas sa
puissance à ne pas partir comme ça on
doit absolument super bien se préparer
pourquoi on n'a qu'à aller directement
chez le hibou oui mais si on se perd
poules mouillées meyrals attend le hibou
n'a pas encore fait sa pelote de
réjection quoi il lui faut du temps pour
la faire à quelle heure il a attrapé
pipe à 16h03
comment tu peux être aussi précis dans
ses juste que ça m'intéresse donc ça
fait dix exactement 14h55
ouais des [ __ ] les hiboux attrapé pipe
il nous reste encore au moins deux
heures ben c'est parfait ça nous laisse
le temps de nous préparer
vous savez sifflée avec vos doigts si
désespère on pourra l'entendre et moi
aussi
on peut l'entendre de londres super idée
ouais et c'est toi qui l'a fait
j'en fais bien moi aussi haut et c'est
très utile vous devriez tous en avoir un
c'est à l'expédition chasse à la pelote
ça commence maintenant
[Musique]
vous avez pensé
à orthez
m
mais si on perd de notre chemin
[Musique]
j'ai pris 6 degrés dans cette poubelle
on s'entoure à des enfants
[Musique]
tous les petits
la vie
soldats d'unités vous êtes prêts
[Musique]
fait voir ses lettres d'amour c'est pas
du tout une lettre d'amour c'est juste
pour prévenir les gens en cas d'urgence
j'aurais préféré une lettre d'amour
en avant marche
si c'est lui je pisse en douce presque
atteint celui là où celui là celui là
d'accord 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 14 15 stop
celui là où celui là celui là
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15
[Musique]
c'est
samon il se trompait
et
je les crois bon vent ce matin mais
elle est au bout
on est perdu oui là on a un problème
heureusement on peut retrouver notre
chemin bas où sont passés mes petits
cailloux je pense qu'il faut aller par
là c'est sa flore ouest puis j'ai froid
et mes vêtements sont tous à l ve arrête
de te plaindre
le voilà est la limite de 5 m
[Musique]
c'est trop dur rejoindra sa balle et je
vais me débrouiller
[Musique]
et
moi
[Musique]
une belote
mais romero
[Musique]
et
miam
ils ont trouvé la pelote
[Musique]
sa vie elle la wii elle a trouvé mort
on aurait pu y penser plus tôt mieux
vaut tard que jamais
je suis là s'il a trouvé hôtels now one
génial tu me dis oui alors elle est où
là aussi vous abonner voilà j'ai une
idée
vas-y montes tu peux aller à l'eau voilà
c'est ça mais ta jambe de ce côté là toi
ok
vas-y je te dis comme ça ouais très bien
ça toi bien
je monte vas-y
[Musique]
ça va oui
c'est ça un peu plus jeudi à gauche à
droite oui moi c'est ça tu vas l'avoir
[Musique]
attrapé suspension elle doit surtout pas
être mouillé
[Musique]
tiens merci beaucoup
donc ça veut dire que pipita l'intérieur
oui en tout cas tout saison
[Rires]
alors il faut qu'on aille par là
[Musique]
attendez je suis pas sûr on est vraiment
perdu non regardez
madame vous arrive on est désolé est ce
qu'on sera privé de spectacle madame non
non c'est hors de question
la chance estimé voir j'aurais dû vous
renvoyer chez hbo immédiatement et
qu'est ce que j'aurais fait si vous vous
étiez perdu on n'aurait pas pu se perdre
bah non on avait des petits cailloux
avec nous et puis un code en morse et
vitaux nous avait préparé un super kids
day sur 10 non non vous avez de la
chance je ne vous renvoie pas chez vous
mais vous devrez de toute façon
participé au spectacle
bref leur antre show pas de commentaire
on y va maintenant on à ses pairs du
texan
[Musique]
on nous dit tu connais l'histoire de la
cigarette qui parle à une banane elle
fait un tabac important
[Applaudissements]
turquie devrait y fille et maintenant
aller au dans un numéro de magie
effrayant
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ou pas le sauveur nos animaux musicale
avec des idées zone mera lévis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
petit côté regarder et maintenant dans
ce cas délicat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
com
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
à
m
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
son parti l'a
[Musique]
nous
j'ai des pincettes spéciale à la maison
on pourra enlever les eaux de pipe avec
we were mbende
[Musique]
je
ça
oui
alors quitté bien amusé ici décibels tu
t'es fait des copains là bas si contente
[Musique]
je crois que j'ai en bout de crâne et là
c'est un morceau de pâte
tu peux me dire ce que c'est c'est un
morceau de pabos il faut essayer de les
mettre ensemble ouais comme ça tiens
j'ai des petits zoo tu peux me dire
comment ça s'appelle déjà des côtes
saisi là il fait comme un petit museau
fola ça c'est le haut du crâne
oui sa tête c'est moi qui l'ait je crois
qu'il faut la poser là c'est quoi
voilà maintenant c'est dans son tout
propre tiens merci le dernier ross de
pipi et voilà on a terminé merci
beaucoup
ces bois tient comme ça on va pouvoir
l'enterrer
mais je n'ai pas envie de l'enterrer je
veux le donnait à jay z
c'est vrai vrai de vrai alors je
reprends ma boîte du coup donnez moi vos
contrats s'il vous plaît je ne vais pas
avec moi mes désirs de jeunes ont le
leur
on n'est plus amie maintenant bien au
contraire on n'a plus besoin de contrat
on va geler 2 3
tant pis c'est pas grave
à notre décharge 16 ans est encore tout
un art que dans ce contexte il est cuit
et l'autre qui voudrait pas qu'on le
laisse rêver regarde ce pc mais tout
ensemble
[Musique]
c'est vrai que c'est pareil
y'en a un d'entre nous qui est mal est
ce qu a appris qu'elle avait tous des
primes à la pierre s'il voit quelqu'un
comme un message est question ici de
tout ça dérange pas pourrions de cornus
[Musique]
ressemblent tous
il
[Musique]
coccinelle signalèrent si gentil est en
réalité super agressif et tel massacre
les pucerons faire tous les jours à
basta c'est pas méchant
[Musique]
les deux robes c'est sa raideur les
permis ne paie qu'une bouchée du pinson
[Musique]